How should you behave on Facebook
and how should you behave on Twitter?
I think Twitter drives
me a little bit crazy,
you know,
um,
I'm on it a fair bit.
I'm not sure it's a good thing.
And I tend to distribute
things that are alarming,
let's say in some sense maybe
they are alarming ideological,
ideologically,
they're disturbing.
And I was thinking about that
today in preparation for this talk.
And I wasn't really sure
that was necessarily a good
idea because there are a
lot of alarming things
happening all the time,
everywhere obviously.
Um,
and now we can share all of
them always all the time.
And so that means that instead of
hearing about one alarming thing a day,
you're hearing about like
500 alarming things a day.
And so then,
you know,
what are you supposed to do about that?
Is that,
does that indicate the state that
there's a state of emergency?
Well,
you don't know cause you don't know
how to calibrate the information.
So I was thinking,
well maybe the right way to behave on
Twitter is only two forward good things
that are happening.
You know,
cause there's lots of good
things that are happening.
But I actually don't
know the answer to that.
I,
I have no idea.
And I don't think
anybody else does either.
I do know that there are studies with
regards to Facebook that showed that the
more time that you spend on Facebook,
the more depressed you are and that it
looks like it's a causal relationship
rather than just a
correlational relationship.
And it seems to have something to do with
the fact that Facebook is one of those
platforms where everybody puts up
an advertisement for their life.
Right?
It's like,
here I am with my new girlfriend in The
Bahamas being happy and here I am in a
mountain being happy.
And it's like,
it's not you like miserable
with the cover over your head,
unable to get out of bed.
You don't,
you don't,
you don't broadcast that.
You can think,
well,
it means you're presenting people with
a falsely positive view of your life and
then they compare their lives to it
and they come up short and you think,
well that's a kind of deception.
But by the same token,
you don't stop random strangers on the
street and tell them how miserable your
life is.
Right?
They don't want to hear about that.
They,
they want to see a facade of normality in,
in,
you know,
just casual day to day interactions.
And so part of pro social behavior
is only to put what's at least,
you know,
normative and good forward.
So it doesn't matter.
I mean,
so I don't think that's
necessarily deception,
but the mass consequences of that is
something that we don't understand at all.
And so,
well,
so with that sort of introduction,
I'm going to kind of walk you through my
experience with social media and let's
say the old media,
for lack of a better word,
and I'll try to give you a
balanced account and to tell you,
well,
it's to see if I can draw some
conclusions about what's happening.